[Music]
let's go to brian in
los angeles hey brian what's going on
brother
hey how's it going
we're doing all right how are you
good good my question is how do we
handle the fact that my mom has chosen
the death with dignity option to end her
life in the coming months oh man so what
brought her to this uh
death with dignity by the way um that's
just particular state you're in they
call assisted suicide right
correct um so what what is
what's going on in her world
um april 2018 she got diagnosed as stage
four glial blastoma wow
um
since then she was driving as of
probably about a year ago she's still
driving still talking still doing great
she has declined and hasn't driven in a
while now because of a seizure or
something she had so
never the fact where
she is declining but she's still able to
talk to us you know not really
communicate well with the grandkids
attacked her speech first
um but
she's
it's kind of one of those weird deals
where the kind of rules in california
are
you have to be able to mix it yourself
it's a drink you have to mix it yourself
that's right take it yeah versus someone
else give it to you so you have to do it
yourself you got to take it before
you're bad enough not to or else then
you never have the option right so it's
a weird balance
well and i think the reason they do that
is twofold one is
it's it's there's still some controversy
in the medical community about
if i give you an actual if you don't mix
it yourself if you've got to go to one
pharmacy to get one thing and go to
another pharmacy to get other things so
it's kind of it's the doctors absolving
themselves of i didn't give her that
thing she got one piece over there one
piece from over there
and the other part is it helps
my understanding is it helps delineate
those who are trying to make an
instantaneous decision and they still
have all of their
mental and physical capacity right so
yeah absolutely um man so is she in a
lot of pain on a constant basis or is
she just exhausted like walk me through
where she is
she's more exhausted her biggest thing
is she doesn't this is where you know
you know what's his three kids i'm the
youngest
um
my wife and i of course would rather
take care of her than let her do this
you know other kids feel differently but
it's she's doesn't want anyone taking
care of her is kind of the
bottom
bluntness of her personality she just
doesn't want to be a burden on anybody
but right now you know she's
she can still talk to us she's just
she's not in a lot of pain she has some
weird pain issues sometimes but nothing
that medication can't take care of has
she given herself a date
it changes daily kind of best on based
on her
i guess mood that day just as of
her sarcasm coming out probably but
she has supposedly six months take it so
right now she says february which you
know april mid april is her six month i
guess expiration date of the medicus
medication but she we get the medication
and holding it at her friend's house
until she's ready to do it kind of thing
um
so it's just it's kind of one of those
things well what does she also decide to
do in december or in november or well
our heads you know so much more yeah
so this what a strange place to be is
i've i've read about and um
had discussed with with you know
experts about the actual patient the
actual client here
i have never sat down and talked to
somebody whose mom has made this
decision
and it feels
unwieldy for you too huh and you got
brothers and sisters that are all in on
this
yeah so everybody knows so
you know my mom kind of just we knew
since she was diagnosed
that
like she sat us down the week after was
like hey look like
when it comes down to this i'm going to
fight for my right
as a californian or whatever you want to
call she's from she was a nurse in the
medical field for years so that's my
right
yeah
i want to
take this so that i'm not a burden or
i'm not in pain or that whatever reason
it is
she wanted to do it from the very
beginning so for the past couple years
you know she's right now she's in this
she says she's in the 16th percentile of
like length of life after diagnosis
okay they gave her 18 months and 24
months and she's at three and a half
years she's on borrowed time now anyway
in her mind correct okay in her mind
even in our mind too like we do
understand like she is living longer
than usual right so we all understand
that we all understand
she is declining it is going to come
but just the fact of knowing someone's
going to commit suicide
ahead of time is like totally different
than
most of the deal with it you know what i
mean yeah like it's for sure gonna
happen
and you got little ones too
i got two five-year-old twins and a
three-month-old
man
and then my brother has a ten and
eight-year-old so it's kind of the
ten-year-old's the closest to grandma
which is you know that's up to them how
they handle it but my five-year-olds
they know she's sick i don't think they
understand
the extent of it and they're five so
it's kind of
you know we have our own opinions but
do our opinions even matter when it's
her you know her choice to do this her
right does a lot of medical
professionals say well so that
that's the best
safest most peaceful place to be
which is a couple of things here um well
let me ask you this i don't want to
start answering questions that you don't
want how can i help you i'm as open as
can be just kind of like
how do i handle it with my i guess my
twins it's just you know you talked
about the amazon books before you talked
about yeah i'm explaining you know
people are gonna you know pass away and
they had a grandma sorry a great grandma
died yeah a little over a year ago so
they kind of understand grandma went to
heaven you know stuff like that right i
understand
and doesn't really bother them you know
i have a little brother actually i was
actually the third fourth four child
little brother died when i was
eight and he was two and i don't really
have that my sister of course she's you
know six years older than me four years
older i'm sorry she's
has
that in her head right so he remembers
all that she dealt yeah there's stronger
there for sure where i don't have that
trauma i don't worry about my kids as
much everywhere more i guess about
my feeling my wife's feelings and how
we're going to handle you know the anger
and the difference in grieving and all
that
it's like okay we're going to get a
phone call one day saying hey i'm going
to take the pill in three days it's just
me right right we call it the pill but
it's the doctor the drink yeah all right
so here's how i'll walk through with you
and this is just my thoughts on this and
obviously you and your wife are going to
do what you're going to do but here's my
thoughts on it
the first thing is i want you to be
angry at cancer not at mom
and you named a couple of things that um
i've heard about i've had conversations
about i've read about which is suicide
often comes down to this it hinges on
this perceived burdensomeness
there is the
um i'm in pain or i want the pain just
to stop
or i have a bleak future but often it
will hinge on
this third leg of the stool which is
people are better off with me not here
and that's where a lot of folks will
lean into and say whoa whoa you were
misguided there
your mom has a unique seat in this is
that she's been a healthcare
professional she has watched people
deteriorate
and get sick and lose their faculties
and i do understand
i have a different perspective of pain
and death having sat in crisis response
stuff
and so i have a different person my dad
is a homicide detective has a very
different picture of death and the
reality and those kind of things so a
lot of people who see it up close have a
very different perspective than those of
us than those others who
death is more
ethereal it's a it's an idea we know
it's going to happen we don't really
know what it looks like and how it feels
on that
i sympathize with your mom feeling like
her body was taken from her
and she will exact control one last time
there's a part of me that wraps my head
around that
and who feels like my body betrayed me
but i will go out on my terms
and i don't ask us a lot you know do we
approve or do we understand i'm like mom
i don't approve but like i can say i
understand where you're coming from but
i can't ever say i approve of it you
know what i mean it's one of the rights
right so what i want yeah and i don't
want to get into the there's so i mean
within the medical community within the
with every community's got their
thoughts and opinions on this i don't
want to get into it
but i want to get into the situation you
find yourself in this and so here's
here's what i'm doing if i'm you
i would make peace with my wife that
this is happening
and
every one of our parents will pass away
at some point period
the the
i've sat with too many people who it was
a shock it just came or they found out
that their you know dad had cancer and
he was gone in three months or there was
a car wreck or phil or you know a acute
suicide right whatever the thing is
not that this is going to be wonderful
and feel good but you do have a snapshot
in history where you can say the things
that you want to say
like i love you and i'm glad you were my
mom
and
here's a letter that i want you to read
about the impact you made in my life
um here are some letters that some cards
that the kids made because they know my
grandma's really really sick
and
you can choose that route
and basically someone has said i'm
taking this train
you can give them peace on that ride or
you can say
i want you to know as you take this and
drink that you're betraying your son
and you can let the let her leave with
resentment anger and frustration and
sadness
that's really the two places that i i i
think that you find yourself in
and i'm always going to choose the
hospitable route unless it is you know
it's somebody causing somebody else pain
in in our immediate sphere that's a
whole other conversation so
your grief and your wife's grief and
your heart brokenness and all that kind
of stuff i get that and that's real and
that is y'all's grief
but i want that grief as much as
possible anchored into the cancer to the
realization that this
evil disease stole your your mom from
you
not that she chose to go three months
early or four months early or two months
early does that make sense
oh 100
um i do think your five-year-olds um
i think a conversation about grandma's
real real sick
and she's not going to be with us for a
whole bunch a whole lot longer
let's write her cards let's draw her
pictures
if we see her let's talk to her and give
her hugs
my wife did a great job at this when my
her grandmother was in a home and she
was had dementia she was slowly passing
away it's just letting our kids know
that every one of these visits is
precious
and precious looks like holding hands
precious looks like sitting in laps
precious looks like
um
saying with respect i can't understand
you can you say that again
and it was hard it was heartbreaking but
it made the funeral a moment of
celebration not a moment of shock
and it gave us a language for six months
later when it's like hey we're gonna go
see a great grandma and it's like well
great grandma passed away
and so we were able to have that
conversation because we laid the
groundwork up close i mean up up up
river if that makes sense
um
i'm sorry man
thank you i hate this for you
and i especially hate it because you've
got brothers and sisters that are all
over the place and it feels isolating
and lonely huh
uh somewhat yes
it's okay to say it i know you're tough
it's a whole it's a whole nother
phone call on that one
brothers and sisters always are right
yup yup um
here's one gift you can give your mom
ask her
what does she want her last days to look
like
say mom i know you've made this decision
you know what i think about it and
that's the last i'm going to speak on it
i want to
extract every ounce of joy and
connection with you that i can in the
last few months that you choose
what do you want this to look like
lots of visits you want to sneak away go
to heavy metal concert together do you
want to eat cheeseburgers every time you
want to just eat a steady diet of gummy
candies and i'm projecting it but here
what do you want the last few months to
be
and i can't think of a greater gift you
could give somebody who's made up this
decision who's got a terminal
diagnosis
who's feeling their body leave them
every day
to say how can we honor you in this last
season
in that moment of service that's a gift
you can give to your five-year-olds and
they are not old enough to understand
you know assisted suicide dying with
dignity they don't need to know any of
that stuff at all
um but they do need to know hey
grandma's asked us to come see her she's
very very sick and we're gonna go this
is this is what love looks like
and you can give her an opportunity to
speak into her final days
the whole thing is heartbreaking and i'm
so sorry and it starts with the cancer
and it starts with these hard
conversations and that i can't imagine
pulling my kids together and say hey
kids
i'm making the choice to be out but i
also understand it too hard hard season
for you and your family
confront it directly walk into it and if
you're me
if i'm you i'm making the choice too
extract as much joy as possible out of a
messy situation